[موسيقى]
يسمونها
السياحة الانتقامية والانتقام من أجل العودة إلى
عامين من الوباء
، ولذا هنا في فرنسا التي
تقول وزارة السفر إنها الوجهة السياحية الأولى في العالم ،
والفنادق والمطاعم ،
والقوارب ، والمتاحف والعروض مكتظة
وليست فقط  أيقونات باريس
التي يهتم بها السائحون
من سان مالو إلى سان خوان تحميل عادي
بعد أن تتجه حمولة الطائرة
للمسافرين إلى الشواطئ ، إنها
أفضل بكثير من عام 2018
وهو أمر جيد جدًا
لمحلات المطاعم للفنادق ذات
الطلب الكامل لذلك  مرتفع لدرجة أن أحد
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في شركة الطيران قال إن العملاء سيدفعون
أي ثمن تقريبًا للسفر في رحلات ترفيهية فاخرة ، كما
وصفه ، ولكن ليس فقط
المسافرين الراقيين المهووسين بالسفر
هذا الصيف
في المخيم الذي يلبي احتياجات
زبائن أكثر تواضعًا ، مثل
زوجين نرويجيين شابين.  وسارة كانوا يجعلون
أنفسهم في المنزل طوال الليل
بسبب قيود السفر المرغوبة
، كانوا عالقين في قضاء إجازتهم في النرويج
العام الماضي ، لذلك هذا العام  لقد أرادوا
الخروج والسفر ، أردت فقط الذهاب
في إجازة ، نحن فقط نحب فكرة
أن تكون حراً في فرنسا ويمكننا
السفر مع الطقس واستكشاف
أي مكان يكون طبيعيًا في ذلك اليوم ،
لذلك كان السفر ممتعًا مرة أخرى ،
نعم ممتع ولكن معقد  بالإضافة إلى أنهم اضطروا
لقضاء ليلتهم السابقة في
ساحة انتظار سيارات بالمدينة لأنهم لم يتمكنوا من العثور على مكان
للتخييم به مكان متاح
تعتقد أنه مع ازدهار الأعمال التجارية ،
لن يكون هناك ما يشكو منه
جيدًا فهذه هي فرنسا حيث
يمكن ذلك في بعض الأحيان  يكون الكثير من الأشياء الجيدة
في مطعم كيمسي عبد الحوفميد الواقع على الشاطئ
، حيث يدير الموظفون ما
أصبح ماراثون وقت الغداء اليومي في
محاولة لمواكبة
العملاء ، والمشكلة التي تقول أن
المطعم يعاني من نقص حاد
في المساعدة المؤهلة
وما شابه  الكثير من الآخرين هنا وفي
أماكن أخرى حول
العالم تلقي باللوم على الطمع وأعتقد أنهم اكتشفوا
أنك تعرف طريقة جديدة للحياة أثناء
الطمع والإغلاق واكتشفوك
يعرفون أن لديهم أمسيات وأن يقضوا
وقتًا عائليًا والآن لا
يريدون التغيير
ولكن هناك شيء واحد على الأقل
هنا قد تغير
بالتأكيد هناك حشود على الشواطئ
واليخوت الكبيرة والمرافئ ولكن
غابت بشكل ملحوظ عن هذا  في العام ، تم حظر أسلوب إجازتهم
الواضح في بعض الأحيان في الروس
هذا العام
بسبب العقوبات التي فرضتها
الحرب الأوكرانية
في فندق رويال ريفيرا ،
يتذكر برونو ميركادل جيدًا عملائه الروس على
مدار 20 عامًا كمدير ،
فنحن نحصل على جولة كاملة في
الفندق  هنا ، على
وجه الخصوص ، عائلة واحدة في شهر مارس
انتهى بها الأمر إلى دفع فاتورتها نقدًا بعد قطع
بطاقات الائتمان والتحويلات المصرفية
بسبب العقوبات ، كان
من الصعب عليهم الحصول على
أموال من البنك لأنهم اضطروا
للذهاب  بالعودة إلى روسيا للحصول على المال ،
أعتقد أن الأمر كان صعبًا
بالنسبة لبعض الروس ، تقول ميركادل إنه ليس السياح الروس فقط
هم الذين اختفوا ولكن
المقيمين الدائمين
بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، فإن الطريق من الفندق الذي يقيم فيه ، هو واحد
من 61 عقارًا وضعتها الحكومة الفرنسية
على قائمة العقوبات الروسية
، قم بإطلاق الجرس لمعرفة من هو المنزل والمسؤول عن الفندق جيدًا ، هل كان
عرضًا إباحيًا بطيئًا ، لقد
قلت الصيف الجديد للحفاظ على
التلفزيون  الأمريكيون
يتشبثون بك على
ما يبدو لا يريد التحدث
ولكن لا أحد يبدو منزعجًا من
غياب الروس هذا العام
خاصة وأن الأمريكيين أخذوا
مكانهم ، فأنت تعلم ما هو العنوان الرئيسي
في صحيفة الصباح يقول
عودة الأمريكيين وبعد عامين.  سنوات من
kobud يقضونها بجنون
[موسيقى] ،
لذا إذا كنت تسافر في هذا الاتجاه
هذا الصيف ، فلا داعي للقلق بشأن
الاقتصاد الفرنسي أو الروس ، ولكن
قد ترغب في الاستعداد
للحشود في الطوابير الطويلة
وأوه نعم  أسعار
جيم bitterman CNN على الساحل الجنوبي لفرنسا